hi I'm Al Gore and I'm doing a wired
auto-complete interview I work on
solving the climate crisis okay is
climate change
urgent yes extremely urgent these
extreme weather events are becoming much
more frequent just in the last eight
years in the US we've had ten so-called
once in a thousand year events is
climate change
scientific fact well the scientists tell
us that his they have known the basics
of this for 150 years and they say that
it's as established as like gravity is
climate change reversible we have
already caused some damage some of which
is not reversible but here's the key
fact the truly catastrophic consequences
of global warming can still be prevented
okay is climate change political some of
the large carbon polluters have been
pumping a lots of money into lobbying
and campaign contributions and that has
made it political in a way that's that
it's not in any other country is climate
change being stopped no not yet but like
a lot of other social revolutions in the
past the abolition of slavery getting
women the right to vote civil rights
movement all of these movements have
seemed like they would never succeed at
times but then when the central question
became clear a choice between what's
clearly right and what's clearly wrong
then the change started really speeding
up that's the point we're at in the
climate movement can renewable energy
create jobs I definitely can't the
fastest growing single job occupation
over the next decade is predicted to be
wind turbine technician can renewable
energy be stored the same kind of
technological revolution that we saw
with cell phones that's now beginning to
happen with batters a combination of
cost-effective batteries and solar
energy will revolutionize the entire
Lansky can renewable energy help the
environment definitely yes by relying on
the burning of coal and natural gas the
global warming pollution that comes from
it is trapping as much extra heat energy
in the atmosphere as would be released
by four hundred thousand her Oshima
class atomic bombs going off every day
can renewable energy power the u.s. yes
absolutely
Wind Energy alone could produce 40 times
as much electricity as the entire world
uses each year the figures are even more
dramatic with solar energy the earth
gets as much energy from the Sun in one
hour to equal all of the energy used by
the entire global economy for a full
year that's incredible
can we live on renewable energy alone
yes we can the big revolution is
electric vehicles every major automobile
manufacturer in the world is preparing
to roll out really cool electric
vehicles that have a range of 300 miles
it's very very exciting ok how can
extreme weather affect the economy big
storms wipe out bridges and destroy
highways and sever interstates
how can extreme weather affect human
health
first of all heat stress puts a lot of
people at risk
second the changing climate conditions
expand the ranges of some of these
mosquitoes that carry Zika and other
diseases can extreme weather affect food
security heat stress on plants pests and
blights plant diseases are made worse by
the climate crisis and a really
surprising finding the extra co2 in the
atmosphere is now beginning to reduce
the nutrient value in the food crops
that we rely on in our diets
how can extreme weather affect our life
massive record-breaking flood events
slides in some areas massive long deep
drought events these extreme weather
events really have a very harsh impact
how can we protect the environment first
of all by speeding up the shift away
from dirty fossil fuels and toward clean
renewable energy we can protect the
environment when we go into the
marketplace by choosing the the greenest
most climate friendly options and
finally you can protect the environment
by letting candidates know that the
environment is important to you and that
you're gonna base your vote in the next
election very heavily on the way that
candidate responds to to concerns about
the environment when enough people do
that we will protect the environment